I always with us in Italy hi Kyle
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show and it's
Francie pleasure getting the opportunity
to you you too sir what's up oh thank
you trying to get my wife on board with
going down the baby steps since we live
in Italy heard you we have six months
left here and she wants to live it up
continue traveling I want to get on the
debt because in six months for Emma
getting out and I'm going to go in the
pharmacy school and that's one your
advice
yeah well Yolo is for children I'm sorry
Yolo is for children that's great you
only live once thank God it's Friday
oh god it's Monday children do what
feels good adults devise a plan and
follow it and so I don't care if
traveling is your plan that's okay as
long as we get to go to pharmacy school
and we have a plan but if you guys are
deeply in debt and broke and you come
out of the military and you move into
pharmacy school all because she couldn't
say no to her princess self that's a
child but if she's traveling responsibly
and enjoying the fact that you're in the
proximity of some of the greatest sites
in the world by being in Italy and she
wants to responsibly take advantage of
that as a part of your budget while
you're achieving your other goals that's
an adult so I'm not saying the travel
makes her a princess I'm saying how she
approaches it and how she looks at it
puts the two of you together it might be
that it's worth it for you to lighten up
just a little bit and slow down your get
out of debt just a little bit on your
gazelle intensity because you have the
unique opportunity for a short time in
Italy to see some of the world's
grandest sights and you'll look back on
it 20 years later and say back when we
were in the military we saw the Leaning
Tower of Pisa you know or whatever right
and so you'll have that opportunity but
but on the other hand you can't spend
like you're in Congress and then go in
to go into pharmaceutical school broke
so you've just got to balance it out
here and I don't know exactly what's
happening here
my guess is I'm gonna give her the
benefit of the doubt and say you're a
super nerd and you got this tightened
down so tight
breathe and she might not be asking for
anything that's that unreasonable am I
wrong uh no you're not I'm yeah I'm the
budgetary she's suspended without said
oh yeah yeah so I think the two you
might lose a small battle to use a
military metaphor to win the war okay
but but you just have there has to be
reasonable boundaries in other words
what I need from her if I'm in your
shoes in order for me to loosen up and
lighten up on my gazelle intensity is I
need to realize I need her to say out
loud that this is a she'll put some
reasonable boundaries on this and it's
not gonna get out of control I mean in
your head so sometimes marriage
counselor taught this when I was arguing
with my wife years ago he talks sharing
to me this he said sometimes when you're
arguing about something for the item
that you're discussing for you it's a
nine out of ten for them it's a 1 and if
you'll talk it through to where you Roz
all she's wanting is a 1 and you're so
you're hearing 9 on spending then you
can get down to that one on spending
lose that small battle win the war of
being on the same team she gets to enjoy
the the locale and as a military wife
and it's one of the benefits of being in
that area and you get to achieve your
overall goals you might not be as far
apart on the actual numbers as it sounds
like because you we've shared an eye
when we were fighting we would we would
digress down into just you know just
over exaggerating everything you know
like her one starts sounding like a 10
and my 9 starts sounding like a 14 you
know and so you know just you gotta look
at guys on a scale of 1 to 10 what is
this and if it's a 1 shut up and do it
you know if it's a 9 she's wanting to
spend then she's gonna have to dial it
down and so it can be that it's just
your perception and how you're coming at
it that you're not hearing each other
that could be helped us we didn't fight
as much after that marriage counselor
taught us that or when we did it was a
better fight a higher-quality fight they
got somewhere with it so um if you're
gonna fight you just need to have
high-quality fights right it's a given
if your hillbilly you're gonna fight
it's a given
oh sure ins from the hills of East
Tennessee frying pan throwing there's an
Olympic event ah
all right there we go baby too much
information on the radio in the first
half hour of this hour